I'd like to move on now to Craig
Walker's very touching photo documentary
more than 2.2 million members of the US
military have served in either Iraq or
Afghanistan it's estimated that one in
five veterans who have returned from
this war suffer from post-traumatic
stress disorder we exhibit symptoms like
depression extreme anger hostility
emotional instability PTSD is one of the
biggest stories of our time and craig
walker winner of this year's Pulitzer
for feature photography spent one year
documenting the life of brian scott
austral now 28 Marine who was deployed
twice to Iraq I'd like to invite Craig
to show us his pictures from a project
he called welcome home the story of
Scott ostrom which was published by The
Denver Post thank you very much I do
want to thank fig and Sheila and the
obviously the Pulitzer war in Colombia
and all of you for coming I'm honored to
be here and a little nervous can we
bring down the lights for the pictures
so all right so we love our jobs every
day we meet we get to meet new people
that do remarkable things but every now
and again we meet somebody that's really
special that person shares an amazing
story with us and then we have this
incredible responsibility to to do them
justice and to tell that story right in
late 2010 my boss and I Tim Rasmussen
did a lot of talking about what our next
story should be we knew we knew what it
was we knew our troops are coming home
we knew that they'd face many challenges
and we knew many of them would be
bringing their challenges home with them
the mental and physical consequences of
these wars are going to linger on for
decades not only for our veterans but
for their families and for the
communities and for our nation and
that's why I'm so glad that I met Scott
ostrom that was fortunate that he was
willing to share such a difficult story
with me before being honorably
discharged Scott served for four years
as a reconnaissance man and the Marines
this included two tours in Iraq and he
attributed his PTSD to to his second
tour in Fallujah this is Scotty was
trying to overcome a panic attack the
day that I met Scott he said the most
important part of his life is but has
already happened the most devastating he
said the chance to come home in a box he
said nothing nothing is ever going to
compare to what I've done and he was
only 27 years old and he basically
thought his life was over and it just
didn't seem fair to me so I met Scott
while I was hiking with a veterans group
in boulder and we talked a lot during
this hike and afterwards he had a coffee
in a great conversation we talked about
his life before during and after the war
and we talked about the project we
talked about and we talked about the
commitment that it would take on both
our parts I really I thought I'd found
the story that I was looking for and
then the following week I called him a
few times left him a few voicemails and
I got no reply and I just sort of
figured that he had a change of heart
and I was basically ready to give up on
Scott when he called me and he was like
totally apologetic hee hee hee as it
turned out he'd spend the last 72 hours
and it locked up in a mental health ward
after an attempted suicide this is him
counting as stitches a few days later
Scott Scott often said that he should
have died overseas and and during a
fight with his girlfriend she agreed
with him and that put him over the edge
and he ended up trying to cut his wrists
with it with a kitchen knife he said
that he thought he thinks that every
combat veterans struggling with PTSD has
a suicide plan and then he told me that
he still wanted to be part of the
project and you know this just confirmed
that that the Scott's story was was very
real and very important so I connected
with him the following day I met his
girlfriend and we talked about we talked
about what happened and we and we talked
about the projects and some more and
this is when I took
as of this opportunity to stress to him
that I can as a photographer I can't I
can't tell your story if I'm not there
when I told him that he really needed to
call me when when things got stressful
and then about three days later he
called and he said hey Craig you better
you better get up here as it turned out
his girlfriend hadn't she was she had
moved all her things out of his
apartment and and in doing so she also
took his anxiety and his sleep
medication so when I got there Scott was
obviously deep in a panic attack anyway
I was just I was just really fortunate
that Scott was willing to share share
these moments with me I I try and be as
meek as possible when I'm in these
situations but when Scott was in his
panic and in his anxiety he was just
like he sort of became so focused with
no tunnel vision that you know it really
I really felt like I wasn't there he
said it's PTSD means that he has
nightmares every night it means that
he's hyper vigilant it means he's he
said it means I'm weird about noises in
the middle of the night and i lock my
doors it means i have i have no fuse and
if i get attacked i'm going to kill this
is him it's sort of in a panic attack
after punching out his door he said his
PTSD comes from long exposure to combat
trauma he said I think it comes from the
fact that I survived that wasn't my plan
it's an honor to die for my country but
I made it home this is scott after he
graduated from boot camp in Parris
Island in june of two thousand three he
signed up because he said he was at a in
a dead-end job he had just totaled his
truck and and he had a crappy job that
paid like ten bucks and I or any and
lived in a in a in a dive he basically
thought he was going to end up doing
drugs or end up in jail so instead of
going to work one day he he went down to
the recruiting station and after after
boot camp he said that he you know he
was really proud of himself and it
he was happy his parents were proud of
them too in May Scott literally wanted
to escape his troubles he was desperate
to move so when his apartment
application was turned down because of
an assault charge in the background
check he literally broke down right
there in front of in front of the
multiple meeting with the apartment
manager he pleaded you know he had his
honorable discharge papers he had his
Good Conduct Medal he said I'm not a
criminal you would think this would be
worth something it should be but it's
not and then the kicker of the situation
is that as he got up to leave the
manager apologized and gave him like
this half-hearted hug and he said thank
you for your service this stuck with a
this stuck with Scott the rest of the
day he hated the phrase thank you for
your service he later that day he was
stewing over and he said uh thank you
for your service thank you for your
service now go yourself that's what
I hear and he said welcome home that's
all that should be said don't thank me
I'm not protecting you from being
attacked I'm securing your leaders
wealth so that's where our where our
title came from welcome home so on this
particular day I knew that Scott's
girlfriend he had obviously gotten back
with her I knew his girlfriend was
coming over to collect her belongings
and I knew there was there's going to be
some confrontation but I never really
expected this she came in ready for a
fight she just sort of started yelling
at Scott and taking everything I thought
she was going to I thought she was going
to get her clothes and her art supplies
but as it turned out she wanted she said
Scott 02 money and one of them wanted as
a laptop and then and then she started
carrying the tempurpedic mattress out
Scott said that they dated for two years
he said he needed somebody to affirm the
way that he felt about himself he said I
felt like if I stayed with that person
long enough and received enough punish
then I have in some way sought
Redemption for my action overseas on
this morning I was on my way to see
Scott I was and I was in my car when he
called me and he said I shouldn't bother
coming up and that he wasn't gonna be
doing anything that day and so I told
him that I'd be there in about 30
minutes because because I knew that what
was going on was probably pretty
important to the story Scott's
depression you know often crippled him
for days at a time he has troubles you
know he said he has trouble sleeping
when he does sleep he has nightmares in
this case you know he said he feels like
a burden to his friends when he unloads
his emotions on him so he often turns to
his dog jobie so on this particular day
Scott and I Scott later on his porch
watching the storm roll in and I had
made some pictures of the lightning
including this one and then I guess sat
down Scott was in a really deep place
and I just sat down and watched with him
and eventually he just broke the silence
and he said I'm just feeling guilty
about the things that I did I was a
brutal killer and I rejoiced in it I was
bred to be a killer and I did it now I'm
trying to adapt and feel human again but
to feel human I feel guilty i did
horrible things to people that's why I
can't eat I feel guilty I feel sick and
let's just kind of pour it out of him
and it was interesting to me because
like throughout the entire the time that
I had spent with him he he never
admitted that he felt guilty he he said
he felt guilty about things that he
didn't do but he never said that he felt
guilty about the things he did he was
always like hey it's not my fault they
were and they were in the wrong place
you know that kind of thing so there was
just a turning point so on this day
Scott woke to another panic attack i had
spent that night at scott's because i
knew that he wanted to try and enroll in
this residential PTSD program at the VA
Medical Center he said that his PTSD was
getting the better of
man it was becoming unmanageable he said
I don't know what I want I need somebody
to tell me what to do and his um he was
he was also really starting to worry
about his health he was losing weight
any-any knew that he needed to get help
he said you know hey I have to or I'm
going to end up on the streets talking
to myself he said we're ending the war
in iraq so forty thousand more troops
are coming home that means a lot of PTSD
and a lot of homeless people I figure I
figure I better get the tools I need to
leave a peaceful and gratifying life he
said i'm a good person so shooting
pictures at the VA is always difficult
and when it comes to mental health it's
near impossible especially in denver so
when i went to the VA was scott i
traveled light i took one camera in one
lens this day was extremely intense he
found out he couldn't just walk in and
sign up for the program but when a
doctor saw house its saw Scott's
condition he gave him so I'm
anti-psychotic medication and sent him
on his way he said I was terrified I
couldn't control my own thoughts but I'm
22 months later Scott was accepted into
the residential program he said you know
eventually you get to a point where you
just break down the only other option
you have is to put your hand up and ask
for help so ultimately in hindsight you
know Scott I think both of us but but
Scott said that he does hope the story
will help our society better understand
our veterans and better understand post
traumatic stress disorder and and you
know hopefully let other veterans in
similar situations realize that they're
not alone so that's thank you thank you
my first question is how do you prepare
yourself for the emotional toll of an
assignment like this you read books you
consult psychologists I mean how do you
psych yourself up for something like
this you know I I spent a lot of time
you know I just went before we started
this I'd spent a lot of time looking at
a young man that joined the army and and
that was what led to our conversation
about sort of the other end I guess and
I did I i think you know i read a little
bit and i talked a little bit but i
think the process of finding Scott was
what really got me prepared was because
I was constantly you know I was looking
for somebody that would share this kind
of story with me and it took a long time
and so I spoke with a lot of
professionals mental health
professionals with people in the army
people in the Marines other groups like
the VFW and just sort of and veterans
themselves people who had already been
through it you know defining as a
photographer finding somebody that was
like right in the thick of it that would
allow me to photograph them it was a
long process so I had met a lot of
veterans already they were sort of on
the other side of it you know they had
amazing stories but they were just
coming out the other side so I think it
was just sort of the process of the
search itself which prepared me to how
did you gain ski said you met Scott in a
hiking trip how did you get his trust
how did you also make sure he understood
the extent of his personal involvement
in this story well I think that's um i
think it was i think it was Scott I mean
Scott trusted me I i think the you know
the most important part about like with
a project like this and pictures is is
making sure that that your subjects
Scott is comfortable with the project
you know I because I met other other
people that were sort of in the same
situation but if there was any
hesitation I would just kind of you know
that you don't want to start with
hesitation so just sort of keep looking
and then I think it's just a matter of
you know being honest and genuine and
and and really explaining what my
commitment was to the project you know I
asked him to have an open door and then
I expressed that I would be there you
know like if he called me wherever I was
I would go so I I think it was just sort
of a mutual respect and trusted we were
can you really be a fly in the wall in
an assignment like this did you ever
feel the urge to intervene like when
Scott is in the middle of his panic
attack didn't you want to go rush over
and comfort him when he was arguing with
his girlfriend did you know you know I'm
sure they're there were definitely times
that I wish that I could help but that's
you know I think that would be kind of
kind of an injustice to to him because
he's willing to share this not not just
with me but would you know he knows that
it's going to go you know in the Payard
online and it's going to be shared with
everyone and I think that you know by
him taking that you know by offering
that and taking that leap for me to try
and like correct it or you know like I
don't think that would be fair to to him
for the word or our readers obviously so
you know I think it's just our
responsibility not to intervene and I
hold that I mean fortunately he never I
mean it like he never I was never in a
situation where he likes slit his wrists
so you know I think that would be
different but but but the argument with
the girlfriend you know and his panic I
mean you know I felt for him for sure I
he's a great guy I'd like to invite our
audience to ask questions just a couple
of questions because we're running a
little bit behind schedule hi my name is
Kate Ferguson I just wanted to find out
at any time were you ever afraid of him
and me
seems like such a bizarre you know
circumstances at times where it's very
unpredictable were you ever scared for
any reason that he might harm you I
think I was a um probably more
intimidated by his girlfriend in the
scene no there was you know there was
one situation where I I went camping
with him for like three days and you
know it it was funny because like it
wasn't me but like a friend of mine was
like hey do you think that's you know
you're gonna be all right with this I
mean you know they they knew what I was
doing and and he's good a lot about
Scott just like are you going to be okay
with all that is there any chance
something could go wrong and I which i
think is what you're getting at like and
it was funny because actually that was
probably when we went camping that was
probably the most at peace that I that I
ever ever did see Scott like you just
sort of talked about how being in the
wilderness he felt like he could totally
take care of himself and he didn't feel
like that and society but you know there
was never really a situation where I
thought feared for my my own safety or
anything yes this editor my name is
shadi Bushra and so there's a multimedia
pieces of video piece on the Denver Post
website and I wanted to know how
involved you were with that part of it
because it seems as though the photo
essay with its captions stands alone
pretty strongly and was that something
that you decided you wanted for the
project or was it something that the
newspaper decided would would be good
for the website and also I noticed that
some of the quotes on the video were
some of the ones you said early on in
your meeting scott so was he asked to
repeat them for the video so it would be
up there or how did that work no we um
we I did it I did the interviews with it
was me and mihaila Gaylord like I just
used to say i used the second care where
she was one of our videographers so i
would i would ask the questions she
asked some questions as well we just
sort of felt that
it's nice to give your give your viewers
a even will just take that take it to
another level since you have that
opportunity with multimedia you know
it's an opportunity to let your viewer
actually meet the person and hear their
voice and hear them talk about it and
tell their personal stories that makes
sense two quick questions from this side
of the room and then we'll ask craig to
answer yes hi I'm Lindsay beaver and I
was just wondering in a story like this
what do you think or why do you think
that photos tell such a great story why
do you think that I guess photos would
tell a better story than same
traditional mediums like print or video
what do you think that you got out of
photos more I don't know i mean i think
that if i'm a photographer I just that's
the way I do it I just you know I feel
that you know there's these moments that
you know we have great writers of the
post that can can paint that picture
with words it's just it's really the
same thing to me whether whether you're
doing it with a camera or with a with a
pen but I am you know I just I love it I
to get I was just I think it's what I'm
supposed to do so net that's why I do it
and I don't know if it was there the
second part of that or was that good
answer my name is Colin I'm in the
stabile program here just how do you
bring such an intimate time with
somebody too close when you appear to
have been perhaps the most stable person
in his sphere at that time how did you
bring to a close how did I what bring it
to a close have you bring it to a close
relation well um I don't think it's
necessarily come to a close I'm actually
in touch with Scott with Scott quite a
bit with the story came to a close
because he had gotten as I said he had
gotten accepted into a residential
program at the at the VA and I also knew
that we were not going to be granted any
kind of access
to the VA to to follow his progress so
that was why we physically well that's
why we ended the story itself but I I'm
in touch with Scott quite a bit I saw
him probably like about three weeks ago
and you know he's doing he's doing all
right he's still struggling but you know
he's moved to the mountains and his back
door opens up to open space and his dog
loves it and so I think he's I think
he's found geographically found the
right place for himself so Thank You
Craig thank you